jonathan taylor thomas was one of the
1990s biggest teen idols
thanks to a series of hit movies and
shows why has he been missing from
hollywood ever since
we've got all the details from the very
beginning thomas was not a huge fan of
the culture within hollywood he enjoyed
a normal childhood in pennsylvania
before he began acting
far from the glamour and scandal of the
entertainment industry
as a kid he loved playing outdoors fly
fishing and spending time with his
friends
in short his upbringing couldn't have
been more different than his life in
hollywood
today in the cafeteria we made bobby
devers laugh so hard
he shot peas out his nose thomas was
lucky enough to hold on to his friends
from childhood
even as his career took off hanging out
with them when he wasn't working gave
him a sense of normalcy he lacked when
he was on set
in an interview with premier magazine in
1996 the young actor described hollywood
as quote neurotic and
weird and said he craved the normalcy of
going home and playing with his friends
with that in mind it's no surprise that
thomas eventually decided that it was
time to pack up and leave hollywood
behind
with impressive credits like home
improvement and the lion king to his
name
thomas had already assembled a very
impressive resume at a shockingly young
age
but for a newbie actor especially one
still making his way through childhood
working so hard came at a high price
while there are legal limits to how long
child actors are allowed to work in a
day
thomas still felt over taxed between
acting going to school preparing for new
roles and trying to maintain
some kind of social life the young
talent was busy at all
hours of the day this intense workload
eventually started to affect his health
he often showed up to work on home
improvement feeling under the weather
simply because he was dealing with so
much stress at such a young age
as he explained to people magazine in
1994 you have school
friends learning your lines and making
sure your performance is up to speed
i can't tell you how many shows i've
done with full-blown migraine headaches
it's clear that thomas rarely had a
moment to himself during this time in
his life
coming down with migraines at the age of
12 due to extreme burnout definitely
seems to have played a role in
discouraging thomas from continuing to
act full-time as an adult
thomas's status as one of the biggest
teen idols of his era might seem
enviable
but attracting that level of constant
insatiable public attention isn't all
it's cracked up to be as thomas told the
new york times in 1997.
it's sometimes distracting to look over
and see a whole group of girls staring
and giggling
you are a part of their life and there
is a lot that has owed them
but it's difficult because you want to
make everyone happy but if you try to do
that you're setting yourself up for
failure
in a 1998 interview with conan o'brien
thomas said that being approached by
fans at
inopportune times could get awkward he
went on to recount a particularly
uncomfortable encounter in which an
eager fan approached him
in saint patrick's cathedral when
o'brien asked him if he was still going
by the nickname
jtt thomas replied i'm over that i've
always been over that as an adult he
prefers to live a very private life
which is a luxury he certainly did not
have when he was younger
thomas became very successful at a young
age due to his natural talent for acting
but even during those years when it
seemed like he was absolutely destined
to continue acting into adulthood thomas
remained open-minded about pursuing
other career paths
at the height of his fame thomas was
clear-eyed on the reality of his life
options as a child star
in his 1996 conversation with premier he
discussed one of his most impressively
mature beliefs
namely that the reason so many child
actors struggle to deal with the demands
of the industry as they get older is
because they have never considered that
acting might not be the right career
choice for them after all even in 1996
with his career at its apex thomas
resisted putting all of his eggs in one
basket
in fact he believed that doing so would
mean courting failure as he told the
magazine at the time
he didn't want to base his life on quote
one thing
thomas always worked hard in school just
as he worked hard when he was acting but
eventually he realized that it was
becoming downright impossible to balance
both
especially while holding himself to a
high standard ultimately thomas decided
that he needed to take some time away
from acting in order to finish his high
school education
when thomas came to this realization he
was still working on home improvement
the popular young actor knew that
leaving would be a disappointment to the
show's legions of fans but he had to
make the best choice for his future
so in 1998 thomas left the sitcom for
good
after thomas graduated from high school
and set his sights on college he
reflected on his choice and
realized that he had absolutely made the
right call during an interview at the
1999 nickelodeon kids choice awards he
said he worried he would have wound up
in a quote early grave if he had tried
to keep up the balance between work
and school although thomas's reasons for
skipping out on home improvement were
understandable his co-stars still felt
disappointed by his sudden exit
particularly when the young actor
refused to return for even cameo
appearances as the series reached its
end thomas's choice to focus on school
rather than coming back to say goodbye
to the show in its finale
became a particularly tender spot for
his colleagues and it seems like he may
have burned some professional bridges as
a result
as patricia richardson who played thomas
mom jill taylor on the show told tv
guide at the time
it's a pretty sore point around here i
think there were a lot of bad feelings
all along
i don't think it's a good idea that he
didn't show up but i don't always think
he gets the best advice
home improvement star tim allen was also
upset by thomas's refusal to return for
the show's highly anticipated finale
episode
particularly when thomas reportedly
seemed irritated to be asked allen later
told tv guide that thomas was quote a
little miffed at him about the split
particularly when the older star began
complaining publicly about his former tv
son's refusal to participate for much of
the show's final season
the pair eventually mended fences though
and thomas appeared as a guest star on
allen's later sitcom
last man standing hey mike baxter hey
andy look familiar
thomas could have probably continued
acting full-time after finishing high
school
had he been interested in doing so but
instead he chose to go down a different
path
one that involved far less time as the
teen heartthrob known as jtt
instead of getting back in front of the
camera thomas decided to pursue higher
education
he had always worked hard to earn good
grades in school even as he juggled
homework with time on set
suddenly he had the opportunity to
simply focus on academics without
juggling acting as well
thomas's college years were richly
multifaceted he enrolled in harvard and
was eventually able to study abroad at
st
andrews university in scotland later on
he ended up at columbia university where
he graduated from the school of general
studies in 2010.
thomas thoroughly enjoyed his time in
college surrounded by more books than
fans and later called it quote a novel
experience after all that time spent on
movie and tv sets in his childhood
there's no denying that thomas was a
major teen idol but time marches on
and every teen idol has to grow up at
some point as many of them discover
early fame doesn't always translate to
success in one's adult years
though his star power didn't necessarily
diminish thomas found it hard to
transition from wholesome family
entertainment to more adult roles as he
aged
compounding this problem was the fact
that while thomas fans weren't
necessarily ready for him to grow up he
was looking to take on more challenging
roles that took him out of his comfort
zone however he was
also at peace with the idea of moving on
to something new if going in a different
artistic direction wasn't in the cards
for him
as he told the new york times in 1997 i
would like to do edgier material because
that's what seems to be respected
maybe this will last forever acting will
get you to a lot of places but there are
a multitude of things i can do later on
acting is just one of them though it
might seem
otherwise to the casual observer thomas
did not actually leave acting after
exiting home improvement
and enrolling in college he has
occasionally appeared in movies albeit
minor ones
and even voiced tyler tucker for a short
run of episodes on the hit nickelodeon
cartoon the wild thornberries
although thomas has never again been a
regular on a tv series after his time on
home improvement came to an end
he has continued doing a wide variety of
guest spots
he might have spotted thomas on shows
like eight simple rules smallville or
veronica mars home improvement fans were
particularly thrilled to see thomas
appear alongside his tv dad tim allen on
four episodes of last man standing
and he also worked behind the camera to
direct episodes of the series
however thomas has not acted since 2015
when he wrapped up this short roll
so maybe he stays in front of the camera
really are done for good this time
that said he is still reportedly
interested in work behind the scenes
including more directing writing a pilot
with former home improvement co-star
zachary tybrian and producing a show
called master of ceremonies about the
chip and dale's dance review scene of
the 1980s
with all that in mind perhaps we haven't
seen the last of jonathan taylor thomas
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite child stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]